Oh my God. Oh Wow, whoa.
So we were very nervous,
but at the same time we were excited to
come out of her comfort zone and just
something different than what
we were shooting with. I Dunno,
I think I'm going to be a painter.
Other musicians,
maybe dancers. Oh yeah.
Maybe it could be anything.
Youtube,
we come in and we usually
have music in front of us.
I really had no idea
anything can be thrown at us.
What if it's like a disco band?
I'd love that.
So we are all members of counties,
quartet string quartet based in La,
and we donate a portion of all our
proceeds to charitable organizations
dedicated to animal. Hello,
my name is Maddie Martinez.
[inaudible] Maria cheese style.
My Dad,
she's killed [inaudible] to edition
and it's very special to us.
Ah,
I'm ready.
Oh my God.
Other musicians.
That's great.
Well we could hear it walking in.
I was pretty psyched because I like
Mariachi music lights so joyous and you
can't help but feel happy. And so
you're a Mariachi band. Yes, we,
what's the name of your group
that's Mariachi mean does make it kind of,
any other nation thinks that will
make it go. They think of all edge.
It's an a good patient of musicians.
I play specific instruments that are made
only for the sound of the Mariachi for
someone who was trained class play to try
to play other genres of music has been
great in that regard. To explore other
donors and play like desperate cdot.
It's actually pretty fun.
And besides that we like to empower
women through our music and power people.
Do you know to keep going to
keep pushing to keep learning?
Vicki maybe we could take
like a classical tune.
Maybe we can add something with this.
I don't know.
I have a canon in d or
something. You can, okay.
We can take a piece that we know it's
a popular class when music piece,
but I'm thinking like we
start with something and I
mean like really passionate
and serious.
And then after like one or two phrases,
we'd kind of like more fit and
can second really fun thing.
When you play with a small group of
people, four people, three people,
you're all communicating,
you're all listening to each other.
There's still the basics of rhythm
and the chord structure is all there.
It's kind of scary at the
same time because you don't
know what kind of musical
level they are.
I was curious,
could this fit themselves into this piece
without having music in front of them
and they could immediately just learn
the chords and then they make it sound
like a completely new version of it
guy's gonna come like jump in and try it.
Yeah.
Hours to it first.
What can you tone it is indeed.
So he started playing nicer feeling
thought, you know, the male would be okay.
Okay. So yeah. What do you guys
got? What do we got left Wednesday?
Wednesday is a fountain.
Ah,
classically trained musicians
tend to stick to the notes.
Mariachi players are amazing.
We did a lot of times it could
just learn it by here because debt,
the switch you can drop of a dime.
So block expressing her feelings and
release their emotions through music.
Oh,
okay.
I love that song. The guy, what's
the shallow? Reminds me of Madison.
Very goofy, very upbeat. Very funny.
I made up the lyrics and it was facey
cause they're like one minute and make,
make up the lyrics.
I think they come at good.
I lost you and I thought I was
not going to find youth today.
I found you all my love.
I very antsy to love you.
I believe that you are from Mars.
So it's kind of like,
whoa. Then I, I lost you and then I
found you and then, well yes you want to,
you don't want it.
They're just
excited and happy and easy to work with
and good players will be linked to your
fingers.
Slow motion please like this.
Okay,
hold on.
I actually maybe stand up and show
high and mighty. Please
bold. He doesn't get word
to miss a rhino. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Got It.
That makes it convenient though,
please.
I think should,
can I hear it one more time?
Is it lower penciling?
It has to be high pitched.
It depends on if the song has, you're
happy. You're gonna, you're gonna feel it.
Ooh. Woo. Thank you.
Prying by your insight.
That's so special. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm really excited about what we did.
He was such a cool combination.
That was fun.
I'm looking forward to see.
It's fun and it's nice and it's super
classy with the beginning of this song and
then getting to feel your style to it.
Oh,
I miss it.
We ready? Ready? Let's do this.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh,
thank you.
Thank you. Good job.
Thank you guys. I know
that's it.